let's get to five headlines
[Music]
all right number one a trump supporter
was shot and killed at a protest in
denver over the weekend
he apparently sprayed mace at the
shooter um
who responded by killing him you can see
a photo of the
fateful encounter here uh
mace is is not a lethal weapon so
this would seem to be a disproportionate
response
now the man with the gun is named
matthew doloff
he was arrested for murder at the scene
the interesting thing is that apparently
he was hired as private security by a
local news station that's nbc affiliate
nine news and here's the other
interesting thing
according to city officials doloff was
not licensed as a security guard in the
city
so it would seem that a news channel
hired whether knowingly or not
an unlicensed armed security guard who
then proceeded to
shoot and kill a pro-trump demonstrator
this ought to warrant charges i would
think not just for doloff but
for nine news as well all right number
two keith olbermann
still exists apparently uh it it seems
we haven't heard much from him in recent
in recent years that's at least i hadn't
heard anything from him
i assume that he had returned to his
lair deep in the earth somewhere but he
has reemerged now
he has been uh maybe summoned after
somebody read a curse from an old book
in an attic somewhere
and now he's back on the scene and he's
about as reasonable
and coherent as
you remember listen trump can be
and must be expunged the hate he has
triggered
the pandora's box he has opened they
will not be so easily destroyed
so let us brace ourselves the task is
twofold
the terrorist trump must be defeated
must be destroyed must be devoured at
the ballot box
and then he and his enablers and his
supporters
and his collaborators and the mike lees
and the william bars and the sean
hannities and the mike
pences and the rudy giuliani's and the
kyle written houses
and the amy coney barretts must be
prosecuted and convicted
and removed from our society while we
try to rebuild
it and to rebuild the world trump has
nearly destroyed
by turning it over to a virus remember
it
even as we dream of a return to reality
and safety and the country
for which our forefathers died that the
fight is not just to win
an election but to win it by enough to
chase
at least for a moment trump and the
maggots
off the stage and then try to clean up
what they left
remember it even though two remember it
means remembering that the fight does
not end november third
but in many ways will only begin that
day
yes he says that amy coney barrett along
with bill bard of course trump and a
number of others
should be prosecuted convicted and
removed from
society
first of all when we're in the midst of
you know the media's blaming
donald trump for supposedly encouraging
violence or
encouraging white supremacists which
which he's not doing
but how about this you've got a
prominent i guess i guess he's still
prominent
you've got a prominent voice on the left
at least a well-known voice
saying that amy coney barrett supreme
court
nominee should be removed from society
look i understand that in the feverish
fantasy-fueled minds of leftists
trump is responsible for all manner of
crimes against humanity and so that's
why they're always calling for him to be
arrested
but what crime did amy coney barrett
commit even in their feverish fantasy
filled minds
what what crime are you accusing her of
committing exactly
at least with trump i know what crimes
they're accusing him of committing
like they're accusing him of being a
russian spy okay so i
i understand that it's it's it's
ridiculous but i understand it
what are you even saying that amy coney
barrett did
did she go 12 miles over the speed limit
on the way to dropping your kid off for
soccer practice is that the
is that the crime we're at the point now
where these people they don't even
bother making up a fake crime
they just work themselves into a sweat
and scream that everyone that they don't
like should be in prison
they don't even bother to explain why
that's their argument style
so you say to them uh so here's my view
on this subject
oh yeah well well you should be in
prison
prison go to prison what dude i was just
telling you that
i think batman begins was better than
the dark knight that's that's all i'm
trying to say
um the thing is i i also think
because i know you hear me talking about
this and you're probably thinking well
you're a hypocrite matt because
don't you often say that your political
opponents and many other people should
be locked in prison
well yes i do but i'm a theocratic
fascist so that's my whole thing
right that's part of it if you're
pretending to be opposed
to fascism then this approach doesn't
work
but anyway glad to see that uh olbermann
is back
always elevating the national dialogue
doesn't he
all right number three julie barrowski
is a political commentator more on the
libertarian side of things
she says she was kicked off a flight
because her toddler wouldn't wear a mask
here's the tweet
she says we got kicked off a flight our
two and a half year old wouldn't put on
a mask
we had practiced beforehand but he
wasn't having it
and then she tagged southwest so
apparently she was on southwest she says
southwest uh staff was apologetic i get
they don't make the rules i hope
airlines ease up the rules because this
really limits families with toddlers
yeah um well julie here is being
uh much nicer and more polite about it
than i would be if that were me yet
kicked off your flight
two and a half year old won't wear a
mask of course he won't
of course a two and a half year old
won't wear a mask
here in fact is what i'll say uh and
there may be some exceptions for this
but
broadly speaking if you have managed
to scare your two and a half year old to
such an extent
that he will actually keep his mask on
for hours at a time
then i think it's very likely you're a
horrible parent
and person i
i just i can't even conceive i've got a
three-year-old
almost four uh and and he won't keep his
a mask on and we don't i'm not gonna
force him to uh i
most of the time when we're going in
somewhere i don't even give him a mask
we just go in and uh
and that's it or i'll hand it to him and
then he'll immediately like put it in
his pocket
fine i did my i you know i tried to
comply with the rules i did my part
um two and a half year old though
is that's just crazy to even expect it
and so i'm just trying to imagine
to get a two and a half year old to do
that i mean it's possible you have a two
and a half year old with the
extremely sort of obedient personality
and
extremely cooperative maybe there are a
few of those two and a half year olds
out there
but the vast majority of them are not
going to do that
in order to get them to do it you would
the the
psychological manipulation you would
have to employ
to convince them to do it and keep it on
their face
is unthinkable to me this whole thing is
crazy this is absolutely insane
um and
never mind the fact that
it has been repeatedly shown that
there's very that there's
probably a very low risk of a someone
that's who's two and a half
contracting or spreading the virus um
and on top of that remember that
what we're always told right is you wear
the mask
for me right you wear the mask for me
you don't wear it for yourself you wear
it for other people
and so when we are forcing crying
confused
scared toddlers to wear masks we can't
even pretend we're doing it for their
sake
can we we
we're doing it for us we're doing it to
protect
us to protect us from them
that's what we're doing it's cowardly
it's disgusting it's disgraceful
shame on southwest for that
and yes they have the right to make
whatever rules they want for their
business but that doesn't mean
that if if the rules are insane
um that doesn't mean we can't criticize
it and we can here and we should
number four speaking of insane gal gadot
is uh going to star in a movie about
cleopatra and that's not the insane part
that part you know it's fine
because we live in the dumbest possible
world this has provoked backlash from
people who are mad
that cleopatra's ethnicity or or her
ethnic identity
is being appropriated one person leading
the charge is
abdul el-sayed cnn commentator and
public health doctor
self-described he says so there were no
egyptian women to play
um an egyptian queen yes very offensive
very offensive i'm also scandalized that
they couldn't find anyone who actually
was alive in the year 50 bc
i mean you're telling me that out of all
the 2000 year old people on earth you
couldn't find one to play this role
someone who could
speak authentically to the lived
experience of people who lived 50 years
before christ
of course looked at another way this is
all very stupid very very
very very stupid for many reasons uh not
the least of which being that cleopatra
wasn't egyptian actually she was greek
second uh are there is so
every time we hear this oh you we
couldn't find an actor or actress of of
this
uh ethnicity to play this role well
how do you know there are i mean are
there egyptian actresses who could play
this role effectively who would actually
be best for it
maybe there are maybe there aren't i
don't know you're just assuming it
at the very least if you're going to do
this put forward a person who you think
would be better for the role an actual
person
not an ethnicity or a skin color an
actual person
and then explain why you think they're
better for it
going beyond their ethnicity or skin
color
but all of that is irrelevant because
the third point of course is that the
job of an actor
is to pretend to be what they are not
that is literally the entire job
that is what they are paid to do and it
used to be
that the further uh an act actor or
actress
was from you know the identity of the
role the more impressed we were with the
performance
in other words the more unlike the actor
is from the role
that's that just makes it even more
impressive
think about um uh you know daniel day
lewis
in my left foot playing a paraplegic
he's not paraplegic himself and these
days you could never get away with that
because it would be said well what about
a paraplegic actor i don't know how many
of
parabolic paraplegic actors are there or
are you just saying we can never tell
this story
until we have actors of that
of that identity but you know back then
when it was saying
30 years ago whenever that movie came
out everybody was impressed with the
performance because here's an
able-bodied person
able to portray this role even though
he's he is not that himself but he was
able to effectively portray it
and uh very impressive it was a great
job
acting precisely because he is so
himself
unlike that role
all right number five finally tucker
carlson last week did a segment on its
show where he discussed ufo sightings
and specifically this
new documentary that was just released
called the phenomenon um
here's a clip of the carlson segment
which includes some clips of the
documentary listen
we used to be defensive on this topic
but there's no reason to be there is now
an enormous amount of evidence including
physical evidence that ufos
whatever they are are real why don't we
know a lot more about this because the
government has hidden that information
from us
outrageously but now some of that
information has come into public view
thanks to a new documentary called the
phenomenon
we learned the feds are hiding more than
we thought they were
all we're saying nobody has to agree
that
why it's there but shouldn't we at least
be spending some money to study
all these phenomena should we study this
stuff
the answer is yes and that's all this
was about and
why the federal government all these
years has covered up
put brake pads on everything stopped it
i think it's very very bad for our
country
are you saying that there's some
evidence that still hasn't seen the
light of day
i'm saying most of it hasn't seen the
light of day
it's outrageous and it's not a partisan
question by the way that of course was
former senate majority leader harry reid
of nevada a democrat if there ever was
one
but that's not even the biggest claim he
makes according to the film reed
said that ufos have actually and
repeatedly interfered
with our nuclear weapons capabilities so
where are these ufos from
some researchers told the filmmakers
that their origins are becoming clearer
dr jacques valet has collected purported
metal debris from ufo cases
dating as far back as 1947
that experts are analyzing in a
state-of-the-art laboratory
he was astonished to find their
composition was
unlike any known metal this material was
manufactured
it's not natural it's not natural to
the materials that we have around us in
the lab or
on the earth yeah physical evidence of
extraterrestrial spaceships visiting
earth not a big deal it's nothing
compared like the fly on mike pence's
forehead
and he's right you know the most amazing
thing about all this is that so few
people seem to care
we've got photographic evidence video
evidence physical evidence
of these things and everyone just sort
of shrugs their shoulders
and moves on now i watched the
documentary myself after seeing the
carlson segment and uh as one of the
weirdos who
myself i'm one of the weird people where
i've watched a bunch of ufo
documentaries
in my day i can say that this one this
one is by far and away the most credible
and impressive
of any that i've ever seen um even the
narrator who you heard there
he's i don't know what his name is but i
i recognize that voice i watch a lot of
documentaries in general
uh and he you know this is a guy who
does like ken burns
films and pbs documentaries a mainstream
documentary narrator and the film
includes as you saw
former prominent very prominent
government officials politicians
uh former military officials scientists
these are credible
people for the most part i mean harry
reid i don't know if i'd call him
credible in fact i wouldn't
but even there when it comes to
ideological things i don't think he's
credible but
that he's putting his name next to this
also they've got supposed eyewitnesses
uh lots of photographic and video
evidence like i mentioned all the
documentary
the thing is one objection you often
hear to the ufo claims
is that well if ufos were real and
aliens were
were actually visiting we should have
very good evidence of it by now
why is it that like with bigfoot somehow
nobody's ever come forward with really
remarkable physical evidence or video
evidence of this
why is it that even in modern times
everybody who records one one of these
phenomena
you know manages to get video of it
seems to be recording it with their
grandmother's toaster oven
why isn't it that everyone's carrying
around these really advanced
videos uh um
you know cameras on in their pockets why
why hasn't it ever been captured
well the thing is that's true of bigfoot
yeah that's very good argument against
bigfoot there are a lot of good
arguments against it but one of them is
just
we've never had there's never been
anything close to actual compelling
evidence of that
as far as ufos though actually there has
been
a lot of really good evidence photos
videos physical evidence
it just seems that nobody believes it
even the good evidence nobody believes
and so you start to think what kind of
evidence would the average person
actually need to see in order to
entertain the idea that maybe this
really is
extraterrestrial in origin probably
short of being personally visited by
alien beings
the average person won't be convinced by
the way
um and not to say that i'm convinced as
in i'm
i'm 100 on board that i'm sure that
these are aliens i'm just saying that
this a lot of this stuff is interesting
uh and the photographic evidence goes
back decades there
there have been very interesting photos
of flying saucers from the 50s that have
been investigated by
various government government
commissions and so forth and have been
labeled unexplained as in
they aren't obviously manipulated or
staged none of the obvious explanations
hold so we're left with
what is it so there's something going on
here i i think we could say at a minimum
with certainty
that we have proof of the existence of
aircraft that far exceeds
the known technological ability of
modern man
and we say far exceeds we mean stuff
that is like hundreds of years or more
beyond
our known capabilities it's easy to
speculate of course that some
government somewhere has this technology
and is testing it out but the problem is
that first of all
these sightings go back to the 40s and
50s
if if a world government somewhere
had access to this technology 70 years
ago
you'd think they would have used it by
now in a very noticeable
significant way is it believable that
some other world
power is that far ahead of us and yet
hasn't used that power in any noticeable
way i don't know
of course when you compare that
explanation which seems implausible
with the idea that some intelligent
civilization has visited
which both are implausible which is more
implausible
and you can make a good argument that
the alien civilization is more
impossible but still
there's there's definitely something
going on here and we get to the point
where you have government officials
on the record saying i don't know this
this is weird
that that should make us take notice i
think
all right um of course you always have
to guard against wishful thinking with
these sorts of things because
i would love for it to actually be
aliens just because that would be cool
and even if they're if they're coming
here to invade the earth and kill us all
all right okay let's we had a good run
i'm okay with that too so uh yeah there
there's a silver lining to that as well
so you have to guard against the wishful
thinking when it comes these kinds of
things
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content